[Music]
[Music]
we realize
if you know what's really in yes it's
crazy person
[Music]
yes welcome to this talk by
our journalist residents and I'm
extremely happy over here summer and
then McKenzie is the McKenzie actually
switch training mathematics Eugene
mathematics for Princeton but he's been
doing science writing for the last
twenty years and he's published books
two previous books right the big splat
on the origin of the Moon and the
universe of zeroes the University of
material world leave the universe in in
psychotherapy University of zero words
in zero words so it's a history of
equations and a family it's about
twenty-four great equations that I was
trying to think to myself so I know of
those 24 great equations that I didn't
get to 24 from very corrosive ring that
book as well and today it's going to
talk to us about a book that he's
written in collaboration which is a
peril on history of cause and effect in
science and I just won't say a word
about the program of journals in
residence it's a new program since 2016
that we have been in a science institute
which is designated to bring a
journalist to write science writings
every semester it is not just in summer
to sort of hang out here and to sort of
learn about what we do a theoretical
precise and hopefully to be inspired to
write something about about computer
science and thank you very much for
joining us as a resident program and for
this topic
oh thanks sheffy and also thanks to all
of you for coming out
I've seen a lot of you around here all
summer and so it's it's a pleasure to be
able to end the summer this way so so as
you can see talk is about the one thing
that you know and machines don't and so
let me not leave you in suspense for too
long okay so the one thing that you know
and machines don't is cause and effect
so this is something that humans develop
at least in our infancy as we play
around with with things all the time we
play around with what happens if you
drop a plate we play around with what
would happen if if I were a princess or
if I were a cowboy all of these things
seem like harmless games to adults but
they're really children learning the
rules of cause and effect and how do my
actions affect the world so by contrast
machines and by this I mean artificial
intelligences or machine learning
algorithms or what you want deep
learning if you're into that by enlarge
these do not yet have any understanding
of cause and effect programmed into them
we don't really give them a chance to
understand causation and one of these
central arguments in our book is that if
we ever want to design artificial
intelligence is what's called strong
artificial intelligence then we need to
endow them with the ability to
understand cause and effect both because
we live in a world where things where
one thing causes another and also
because they're going to need to
communicate with humans and this is our
native language this is the way we
understand the world around us so right
now our book is not just about AI
although this is we found sort of one of
the things that's very sexy in the news
media right now and and you can get a
lot of tension if you tell people you've
written a book about AI but really Judea
has been working my co-author idea pearl
has been working on this project for 30
years of reintroducing the language of
causation into
science and one of the things he
realized very early on although he was
motivated by artificial intelligence he
realized that in fact the blindness to
causality was pervasive in science and
the reason for this is the science takes
its cues for analyzing data from the
subject of statistics and statisticians
are in fact very proud of using what are
called model free ways of analyzing data
and they're good reasons for this they
want to avoid bias they want to avoid
imposing the researchers prejudices on
the data and so you start out by
assuming as little as possible about the
mechanisms that produce the data but you
die and I argue that this is
nevertheless in some cases throwing the
baby out with the bathwater
because in fact in reality the scientist
has a lifetime worth of knowledge
cause-and-effect knowledge that they
could bring to bear on the problem and
also a careers worth of knowledge
perhaps developed in collaboration with
other people in the subject and
scientists understand very well what
causes what and you know if you read any
article about biology or you'll see
networks where genomic networks are
whatever where one thing causes another
thing or suppresses another thing so
they understand these things and yet
statistics Orthodox statistics does not
let them bring that knowledge into the
analysis of the data so one of you days
goals then is to make this possible for
scientists to do so I just want to show
you a picture of my co-author you know
you'd have pearl who I think actually
probably needs little introduction for a
lot of you in the audience he's a
computer science legend he's won the
Turing award which is sort of like a hey
Nobel Prize for computer science and
there's a little testimonial in his
honor that Erik Horvitz wrote when he
was
given the territorial art so it talks
about that he's been the heart and soul
of a revolution in artificial
intelligence now you might wonder what
revolution is this and actually that's
an interesting question because you're
daya has been at the forefront of not
one but two revolutions in science which
is probably two more than most of us get
a chance to do but at least one more so
so the one that orbits was probably
writing about was his invention of
Bayesian networks in the nineteen eighty
so this is an approach to artificial
intelligence that allows the the machine
to bring in in a principled way
probability or uncertainty into its
analysis so before your day people had
tried to do this but not actually using
probability theory and it was kind of
their efforts were kind of clergy and
his idea of Bayesian networks really you
know took the took the AI world by storm
so if you'd like to see an example of
Bayesian networks there's probably one
in your pocket it's called a cell phone
every cell phone since the third
generation has had a coding and decoding
algorithm which uses essentially you
day--is belief propagation algorithm and
oh try to keep this very brief but the
way it works when you speak into the
phone your voice is converted into a
string of ones and zeros the digital
signal okay those are called the
information bits those are then coded
using what's called an error correcting
code that's intended to improve the
fidelity of the transmission and then
that code is broadcast is sent out by a
radio signal to the person that you're
calling and then their cell phone has to
decode it and figure out what is the
most likely spoken message to have
generated that code word that have
received and the problem is that the
code word to receive may not be the same
as what was transmitted there are errors
in transmission because radio signals
you know get static in them and what
that does is it'll flip a 0 to a 1
nurdle simple 1 to 0 or it may actually
drop a bit entire
so the innovation in the cellphones is
that you actually set up a network of
nodes and links between them and these
nodes communicate with each other
sending each other information about the
bit that they're that they're
responsible for what do they think it's
a 0 or 1 and the probability enters in
because they're not sure that they may
have a certain degree of certainty about
whether this is your own one and by
sending millions of messages to each
other a second
they eventually arrive at the most
likely guess for what the information
bits were so you might notice well one
thing I should say is that the one of
the reasons you day is belief
propagation algorithm was so successful
is that as fast and so when you're
talking to your cell phone you don't
realize that it's doing all these
millions of messages every second so now
when he was working on Bayesian networks
you day I realized something interesting
which is that when we look at this
diagram we have a very natural
interpretation of the arrows as causes
and effects so you speak into the phone
it causes a code word to be generated
that causes a code word to be received
but there's nothing in the formal theory
of Bayesian networks that requires a
causal interpretation the arrows you can
in fact reverse some of the arrows and
you can still do the belief propagation
algorithm so the arrows are really just
a bookkeeping device and yet we have
this very intuitive sense that that's
just wrong to switch one of the arrows
so he started thinking about whether we
can take this seriously and what does it
mean to have an arrow be in the causal
direction versus not in the causal
direction and so at first he thought
that you could express it in terms of
probability but he eventually realized
that you couldn't do that that they're
actually separate of histological
categories causation is distinct from
from probability and so you need a
separate language for causation and that
language is provided by a causal
diagrams so when you interpret the
arrows as causes this becomes not a
Bayesian network but a causal diagram
couple things to point out about causal
die
grams are first that effects can have
many different causes so that's a little
bit of a that's more flexibility than
for example you had in the 1800s when
researchers were trying to find out the
cause of a disease and usually a disease
has one cause it's a germ that causes
that disease but in 20th century
medicine we have lots of multifactorial
diseases with lots of causes and so this
is a much more appropriate framework to
talk about that kind of situation in
also we don't assume causes are
deterministic this is again sarva
Bugaboo of science one of the reasons
for resistance by statisticians to
causality was the they assumed that
cause meant a deterministic cause and
again I think this comes out of a 19th
century science where in physics for
example if you drop an apple it will hit
the floor you know there's no no
question about what's going to happen
physics is a very deterministic science
with very small errors at least it was
then of course now in 20th century we
know that that's not entirely the case
so so again judea's framework is adapts
very nicely to situations where you have
uncertainty so it's perfect for 20th and
21st century science okay so let me give
you a few examples of causal diagrams
and from the book and what they're good
for the first example is one of my
favorites because it involves my dog
Daisy who's in the pictures and believe
it or not those are four distinct
pictures of the same dog so anyway so
this passage comes from a chapter on
mediation which is
[Applause]
you have the right spot yeah so
mediation is a fancy scientific word for
mechanism one of the things that science
is often interested in is how does a
cause produce an effect so you know you
know cause X produces effect Y but you
want to know what's the what's what's
the mechanism for example if you flick a
switch and the lipo comes comes on
what's the mechanism well
flipping the switch closes a circuit so
electricity flows through the circuit
and then that causes the the filament
and lightbulb to start glowing by
knowing this mechanism you can then do
troubleshooting so if the lightbulb
doesn't come on you know either the
switch didn't close the circuit or you
know that the light bulb burned out so
so in ordinary life we use this kind of
reasoning a lot nevertheless it's been
very difficult for statisticians to to
say what is actually meant by an
indirect effect you know talk a little
bit about why that is in a couple
minutes so one of my roles in writing
this book was to come up with examples
that would be easy to for the public to
understand and so this is my my example
to illustrate the idea of indirect
effects and how do you how do elucidate
them so one other thing I should say is
that the book has written in the first
person so when I say I had actually
means Judaea and when I say Maya
co-authored that actually means me a
little bit confusing I know okay so my
co-author and his wife adopted a dog
named Daisy a rambunctious poodle and
Chihuahua mix with the mind of her own
Daisy was not as easy to house-train as
their previous dog and after several
weeks she was still having occasional
accidents inside the house but then
something very odd happened
Dayna and his wife brought home three
foster kittens from the animal shelter
and the accident stopped the foster
kittens remained with them for three
weeks and Daisy did not break her
training a single time during that
period was it just coincidence or had
the kittens somehow inspired Daisy to
civilize behavior Danis wife suggested
that the kittens might have given Daisy
a sense of belonging to a pack and she
would not have wanted to mess up the
we're the pack lived this theory was
reinforced when a few days after the
kittens went back to the shelter Daisy
started urinating in the house again as
if she had never heard of good manners
but then it occurred two days to Dana
that something else had changed when the
kittens arrived and departed while the
kittens had been there Daisy had to be
either separated from them or carefully
supervised so she spent long periods in
her crate who are being closely watched
by a human even leashed to human both
interventions crating and leashing also
has to happen to be recognized methods
for house training when the kittens left
the Mackenzie stopped the intensive
supervision and the uncouth behavior
returned dana hypothesized that the
effect of the kittens was not direct as
in the pack theory but in direct
mediated by creating and supervision
figure 9.6 which I will show you to you
on the right here shows a causal graph
okay so here you can see the direct
effect on the bottom line okay so the
the kittens leading directly to greater
success in house training and the
indirect effect goes up the top okay so
the kittens cause us to supervise her
more and then that makes her behave
better at this point Dana and his wife
tried an experiment they treated Daisy
as they would have with kittens around
keeping her in a crate and supervising
her carefully outside the great if the
accident stopped they could reasonably
conclude that the mediator was
responsible if they didn't stop then the
direct effect the pack psychology would
become more plausible so I got a pause
here and just say that I think that this
is all very intuitive and easy to
understand
my wife understood perfectly well well
with the logic of this experiment is so
you just simply as I said you said the
supervision level to the level it would
have had if we had had kittens around
nevertheless this is extremely hard for
a statistician to do because statistics
deals with data and data are things you
observe in the real world whereas when
we talk about what would have happened
if there were kittens we're talking
about an
existent world a fictional world where
we had kittens okay right now we don't
so this sort of sentence or this sort of
construction is called a counterfactual
and it's one of the prime centerpieces
of judea's approach to causation and in
fact to causation in general so so for
SAS ditions it's hard to talk about
counterfactuals you can't collect data
on them nevertheless we do in fact
formalize what I just told you in the in
a formula on the next page which I won't
attempt to read but basically the whole
story here about setting the the
mediator equal to the value it would
have had if we'd had the treatment there
that story is essentially codified in
the for in the formula okay so you might
wonder what happened with our experiment
so to finish Daisy's story the
experiment was inconclusive it's
questionable whether Dana and his wife
monitored Daisy as carefully as they
would have if they had been keeping her
away from kittens so it's not clear that
M was truly set to m1 okay so that's
referring to the formula with patience
and time it took several months Daisy
eventually learned to do her business
outside even so Daisy story holds some
useful lessons simply by being attuned
to the possibility of a mediator Dana
was able to conjecture another causal
mechanism that mechanism had an
important practical consequence he and
his wife did not have to keep the house
filled with the foster kitten pack for
the rest of Daisy's life so anyway so
there's this sort of a fine example of
how a causal diagram changed my life you
know at least made my life a little bit
simpler so let's look at a somewhat more
serious example so this is illustrating
another issue that comes up in causal
analysis called confounding so comes
from a paper from the New England
Journal of Medicine published in 1998
they were studying elderly men and
asking whether these men had positive
beneficial health outcomes
regular walking so in particularly they
looked a group of people who walked at
least two miles a day you can call those
the intense walkers and other people who
walked for less than a mile day and we
can call those the casual walkers and so
the question is will walking increase
your lifespan well one thing I want to
say right away is that the data alone
cannot tell you the answer to that
question so they you know the data that
they collected was very impressive so
they observed the mortality rate of the
intense walkers to be about half the
mortality rate of the casual walkers so
this looks really impressive and like
wow I want to go out and start walking
but we can't leap to a causal conclusion
from the data why can't we do that
because there might be confounding
factors so for example it could be that
the people who walk more do it because
they can walk more they're younger maybe
they're healthier and so if that's the
case then perhaps their age is the
explanation so for example suppose we
observed that the intense Walker's were
10 years younger on average than the
casual walkers and suppose we observed
that they also lived 10 years longer
from the beginning of our study well in
that case the effect would be entirely
due to the age and none of the effect
would be due to the walking so this is
an example of what statisticians call a
confounder and it's really easy to
recognize an acausal diagram because you
see a forking arrow pattern the age the
arrow going from age to walking and the
age going to arrow from age going to
mortality so when you see that fork you
know that you were dealing with a
confounder so statisticians have known
about confounders for decades and they
have ways to deal with them they're
fairly simple to understand for example
if if we knew that age was a confounder
we could simply look at 60 year olds and
that way we'd be comparing like to like
and we if we saw a difference than we
could and
the walking was the reason for it
trouble with only looking at
six-year-olds then you're throwing out
most of your data so there's more
sophisticated ways to do it
you can stratify your data by age so you
can look at the six year olds and the 61
year olds and the 62 year olds and look
at the walking and mortality in each
group and you can relate the data so
that the age structure of the treatment
group is the same as the control group
or the walkers and and casual walkers
and that's another way of controlling
for age okay so so in fact the people
who wrote the study did control for age
and they controlled for a variety of
health indicators they controlled for
smoking and they controlled for alcohol
use and so forth they controlled for
basically everything they could think of
and still the walkers had a much lower
mortality rate than the non markers so
you might say okay our questions
answered now so let's see what the what
the researchers themselves said they
wrote of course the effects of
intentional efforts to increase the
distance walked per day cannot be
addressed in our study so in other words
they punted on the main question which
was does walking increase lifespan they
said we can't tell you so we can tell
you that walking is associated with a
longer life span or what's our route
with reduced mortality but they're not
going to say anything about causation so
what you do and I argue is and is that
this is the attitude that needs to
change the only thing I disagree with or
don't like about this paper is those two
words of course because those two words
show me that the researchers have been
brainwashed by their statistical
training to think that in an
observational study like the one they
conducted in other words one where you
don't randomize who walks and who
doesn't walk you're not allowed to make
any causal conclusions and this is
simply not true it may have been true
once was not true anymore
and so so we can address the causal
questions and we should
because the people reading this study or
the people who are going to take some
actions based on the study are you and
me we want to know if I walk am I going
to live longer so we don't want to know
about association that doesn't mean
anything to us so society demands
questions answers to the cause of
questions and if we can provide them we
should now if you're afraid that we left
out some confounders that's okay what
you can do is put in the article you
could put your causal diagram in the
article you show it the confounders were
and there's someone ten years from now
discovers another confounder that you
left out then you can go back and
reanalyze it try to collect data on that
confounder but if you put forth a
good-faith effort to identify every
reasonable confounder then why should
you not then say what your causal
conclusion is because that's the whole
objective of your study okay
now you might wonder is over these
researchers more cautious you know for
some reason than most researchers and
the answer is no in fact just last year
the editors of the Journal of the
American Medical Association which is
one of the leading medical journals in
the country
wrote this on their blog if it isn't a
randomized clinical trial and is a
report of an observational study such as
the one I told you about
then all cause-and-effect language must
be replaced so in other words if these
researchers had tried to say that
walking improves your mortality rate
they wouldn't have been allowed to so
again today and I say that this is this
is an attitude that needs to change and
fortunately we're not the only one
saying it so in the American Journal of
Public Health this spring in May there
were seven papers that all took issue to
a greater or lesser extent with the
recommendation of the Journal of the
American Medical Association for example
Miguel Hernan the Harvard School of
Public Health wrote arguably the biggest
disservice of traditional statistics to
science was to make causal into a dirty
word the c-word that researchers have
learned to avoid and so what you died
and I want to do is to bring the c-word
back into science okay so let me give
you one more example of a causal diagram
and what we can get from it this is one
we actually discuss a lot in our book
it's the question of whether smoking
causes cancer which is a really
interesting historical debate in the
1950s and early 1960s this is a very
controversial question and the reason
was the the leading suspicions to the
time such as RA Fisher said you can't
tell whether their smoking causes cancer
because there may be a confounding
factor such as a a smoking gene that
predisposes you to smoking and the
perhaps also predisposes you to cancer
other people didn't talk about a gene
but they talked about your personality
or your Constitution so maybe you're
just tough tough living son of a gun who
smokes and drinks and cusses and gets
cancer so it all sounds a little bit
preposterous nowadays but there is real
discussion of this so so the situation
here is we have a confounder of smoking
in cancer and unlike our previous
example we don't have any data on the
confounder because in the 1950s there
wasn't the genomics area area we
couldn't identify individual genes we
could barely even see DNA so there is no
way to collect data on the confounder
and so our method of adjusting that I
talked talked to you about earlier won't
work okay because we have no data to
adjust with so what's what today is
discovered using cost diagrams is that
if you can collect data on an
intermediate variable such as tar sour
deposits in the smokers lungs and if you
can assume that that's not affected by
the confounder then you can in fact
separate the effect of smoking from the
effect of whatever this putative
confounder is so so for example the
argument might be that if the tar tar
cumulation is just a physical process
that has nothing to do with your genes
so if you have this set up then you can
you can't in fact get the causal effect
why is this important well because you
can't do a randomized trial you can't
tell one group of people don't smoke and
another group of people please smoke for
30 years two packs a day for the sake of
science okay that that wouldn't get you
very many volunteers even in the 1950s I
don't think so but by using your day is
by using the causal analysis you can
emulate what the result of the
randomized trial would be and as I said
here the auxilary variable lets you
basically lets you pick out what effect
how much of the effect is coming from
smoking and although this example this
particular example can be debated
debated and I discussed that we discuss
that in the book the general framework
is available for any situation if you
have two variables x and y a treatment
and effect and a confounder that you
cannot collect any data on you can still
control for that confounder
if you can observe an intermediate
variable that's shielded from the
confounder this principle is not taught
in any statistics books and yet I think
it should be okay there should be a sort
of standard next thing to try if you
can't do a randomized control trial so
it's called the front-door adjustment
formula and hopefully some people will
start using it yes it's different okay
yeah that's a great question so so she's
asking about instrumental variables and
that's another simple diagram which
basically if you think of the putting a
variable here and having an arrow
leading to smoking and then going
straight to cancer then that's another
circumstance where you can get the
causal effect and only reason I didn't
put that up here is that that was
discovered before you daya I'm says
known for for quite a while but again
the causal diagram allows you to see why
that works yeah and so so I think the
the unfortunate thing is lots of people
know about
instrumental variables but very few
people know about the front-door formula
and so I don't see any reason why this
should be so rare and instrumental
variables should be so common in fact
statisticians have shown great ingenuity
at discovering instrumental variables
and I think if they applied themselves
they could also find these shielded
variables that we talked about here yeah
so it's a great question yeah yeah
absolutely we love interruptions right
right no direct effect yeah that's right
so so and we're using here are in our
intuitive understanding of causes in
fact that we that we form from the early
years of our lives so so we if we
understand the tar deposits are formed
by the literal physical accumulation of
tar in the lungs that has nothing to do
with what genes you have okay or at
least you can make that argument now
okay so sometimes people wonder yeah it
should we be able to draw an arrow the
source starts here and merges with that
so your dad doesn't use doesn't draw
arrows like that if if you have a case
like that that's called mediation sorry
moderation so that the smoking would
moderate that variable so if in a case
like that you know would draw just an
arrow from from tar to from smoking to
tar so the way he phrases it which I
kind of like is that you draw an arrow
from A to B if B listens to a okay so
does tar listen to your smoking jeans do
the tar deposits are they affected
directly by the gene and we're arguing
that the answer is no okay that there's
because jeans work through a whole
different method you know they
transcribe proteins and stuff like that
and that that has nothing to do with the
formation of tar now you can dispute
that and there was a statistician David
Freedman who gave a very cogent critique
a few days arguments and said in fact
that you can't assume that but the the
general principle still is valid that if
you can if you can say that there's no
direct this does not listen directly to
that that the only way it hears about
the gene is by hearing about the smoking
then you can use this front to our
criterion and you can get the causal
effect
yes but you don't need that time off of
you you can you can pare it down so that
you well yeah so okay so you who meshes
question was about modeling and how much
of the model do you need to need to draw
I think that a lot of this discussion
may actually for physical sciences
scientists may seem a little bit odd
because in physical sciences you do have
a model of reality which is expressed
often with equations sometimes not
expressed explicitly you know so for
example we sort of think of turning on
the switch as causing the current even
though the equations are pretty agnostic
about that but in statistics you sorry
in physics you do have models and you
know physicists talk about the standard
model of particle physics so they know
they understand that models are
essential for understanding reality but
in statistics that's not the
understanding so you statisticians see
it as a virtue to have a model free
method for analyzing data so what we're
trying to say is please bring models
back in you know and for people in
social sciences or in in medicine that's
that's already a step forward it's not
something that they do every day yeah I
think your hand was up next
yeah is that you can have lots of
different models that all generate
exactly the same data distribution so
you can't necessarily rule out models
you know you might have two models right
lately cuts in exactly yeah yes yes
precisely you know so in fact we always
have you know there are always data so
if we go back to the previous slide I
think the problem is that you could have
exactly the same observational data
smoking in cancer so two very simple
models one where you have the smoking
gene and one where you don't they
generate exactly the same data they both
very simple you know how do you
distinguish so sometimes I should say
sometimes you can falsify the bottle
based on the data but not always and and
there are many cases where you can have
two different models for the same data
actually we give a nice example of this
and in our article in The Wall Street
Journal this spring and so there it has
to be your your common sense your
understanding of the situation and not
necessarily yours because that may not
just yours because that may make it
sound arbitrary and subjective but if
it's reflecting the consensus of the
scientists in the field then we argue
it's worth doing and if the consensus
changes then you know you have healthy
scientific debate but at least if you
draw the model then you have something
to debate over and that's not common
practice and it's harder to debate over
the assumptions when you can't see them
explicitly
yeah great questions okay let me yes yes
you had a question two founders would
probably introduce more variability into
way
and you might need a higher close-up to
say that this is a relationship point oh
yeah that's a really good so his
question was about the relationship
between p-values and causality so so I
think as I understand that you're saying
maybe to get causality you need a lower
p-value 0.001 instead of 0.05 I don't
really agree with that so yeah so as I
said before causation and probabilities
which is really what the p-value is
referring to our different categories
and there was this going back to the
smoking and cancer chapter there was a
very interesting attempt in the 1960s to
codify rules for inferring causation
that were not quantitative and were not
you know did not have a methodology like
we had here but one of the suggestions
was strength of effect and so for
example in the case of smoking cancer
the effect was so strong the smokers had
a nine-fold greater risk of lung cancer
than the non-smokers and heavy smokers
had a 25-fold greater risk these are
huge risk ratios and so the argument was
because they're so huge this must be a
causal effect but you can easily come up
with examples with risk ratios like that
where it's not a causal effect so so the
the two really I think of as independent
questions and that in many cases years
we would be able to use the same
statistical techniques but we just have
a different interpretation you know and
so where you say walking is associated
with along with lower mortality I would
say walking causes or mortality subject
to this causal hypothesis and you know
that's this were interpreting the same
different data just in a different way
and I would argue I'm doing it in a more
useful way
okay so to conclude with the examples of
the causal diagrams what causal diagrams
can do for us they can tell us what
experiments to conduct that was the
example with Daisy and they tell us how
to interpret our data so in the walking
example they told us age was a
confounder so we needed to adjust for
age they cure the fear of confounding
because we put down our confounders on
paper we say what we're assuming and so
we leave it leave it open to the
community to judge have we controlled
for all the reasonable confounders or
not and if we have then we have every
right and we have the responsibility to
say to talk about causality and finally
they give us new ways to extract this
causation from association and that's
the example of that is today is
front-door formula and there are many
more examples so and this particular in
particular would look like black magic
to statisticians of the 1950s but it's
absolutely possible today so bringing
this back to the conclusion that at the
beginning in the beginning the title of
my lecture was what - we know that hey
eyes don't so let's come back to a eyes
what does this have to do with
artificial intelligence well I want to
show you a picture of what happens when
you have a machine learning algorithm
that does not understand causality so
this is the uber automobile that ran
over a pedestrian in Arizona in March of
this year the first fatality in a
self-driving vehicle and the National
Transportation Safety Board in their
preliminary report on the accident in
May said that the cause was the software
failure what was the software failure
well so as you can see the car is
equipped with the lidar mechanism that's
on the top that's supposed to detect
things in the environment that the car
needs to pay attention to and perhaps
avoid so six seconds before the
collision the lidar detected the
pedestrian but it didn't know it was a
pedestrian
then a second and a half before this
collision it realized it was a
pedestrian and determined that an
emergency braking maneuver needed to be
applied did that happen no it didn't so
there was no emergency braking maneuver
why not
because Ober turned it off so anytime
the self-driving mechanism was engaged
they turned off the emergency braking
assist why on earth would they do that
well we don't know for sure because I
don't work for uber and uber isn't
really saying but I talked with one
expert on autonomous vehicles and I read
an interview of another one and both of
them said that they believe the problem
was spoofing so spoofing is when the
vehicle thinks something is a threat
that really isn't so for example it sees
a sign and it says whoops I better break
or it sees no of has hopes that's gonna
fall on me and I better break so what
actually doesn't think it just breaks
okay so so it was is braking in
situations where it shouldn't know
obviously okay it would have been much
better for uber to try to understand the
source of the problem to try to correct
it but instead what they did was they
just turned off the emergency braking
and hoped that that would solve the
problem and this is what the result was
so I don't know we don't know for sure
what if any causal models they had in
their software probably none but but we
what we can say for sure is that if you
want to put an autonomous vehicle on the
road in a very uncontrolled situation
then it needs to be able to understand
something about causality it needs to
understand that signs are not going to
walk into the road that overpasses
aren't going to fall into the road but a
pedestrian might walk into the road and
you'd better be careful and a great
example of this occurred to me the day
after I gave this talk the first time I
was driving along the road I saw a
pedestrian and I saw him look over his
shoulder and to me that was like a bell
ringing this guy wants to cross the road
he was looking back over to see if any
any traffic is coming so
I didn't need to think about it I
understood you know I understood the
causal sequence there and so a
self-driving vehicle needs to be able to
do the same things it needs to be able
to identify pedestrians identify when
they're a threat and especially if he's
looking if he's going across the road
you need to be able to tell that sort of
thing so you need causal models okay so
this is just a picture from our Wall
Street Journal article I kind of liked
it so so a robot can't tell whether the
rooster crow causes the Sun to rise or
whether the Sun Rise causes the rooster
to crow so you can't tell from the data
the data will show you their associated
you know very you know very often when
the rooster crows the Sun rises right
after that but you don't know what the
data can't tell you the cause or the
effect or whether there even is any
cause or effect okay so so this property
puts machine learning programs of today
mostly at what we call the the bottom
rung of what we call the ladder of
causation so the bottom rung is
Association where where you see patterns
and data you see that the rooster crow
is associated with sunrise but you don't
know what causes what this is also the
level that most animals are at so
Pavlov's dogs associated the ringing of
a bell to food the next level up is
intervention what happens if I if I
change the world if I change my
environment okay so I make a tool to do
something so this is already a a higher
level because it involves doing rather
than seeing and that's a big difference
in our book for example if the animal
could actually think of you know once it
observes that ringing the bell cause
seems to be associated with dinner if it
actually thinks of making a bell and
ringing it that would be already a big
step towards understanding causation in
the top level I mentioned to very
briefly earlier is called
counterfactuals and that's where you're
asking what would have happened if I had
done this so I did this I saw that that
such and such happened and now I want to
know what would have happened if I did
something different
so this is a uniquely human thought
pattern and I think it's a big part of
what makes us human it's part of
morality so when you're when you're
learning morality or you're learning
correct behavior you make mistakes and
you ask yourself what should I have done
what would have been better
so that's counterfactual thinking and we
also came discussed this in connection
with the Daisy example earlier so when I
when we're writing the chapter on
counterfactuals I was struggling a
little bit with okay with examples and
how to communicate this to the general
public and an easy way to understand and
then it hit me that there's a famous
poem by Robert Frost about exactly this
thing okay if my thing will work oops so
the the poem the road the road not
taken' I believe is what's called so he
comes to fork in the road and he says
sorry I could not travel both and be one
traveler long I stood so literature and
poetry are full of situations like this
that are interesting where you're you
want to know what would have happened in
these counterfactual worlds and what's
interesting is not that we wonder not
that we asked the question but the fact
that we can actually answer the question
so often and agree on the answers so
Robert Frost at the end of the poem
thinks he does know what would have
happened he says that by taking the path
I took that has made all the difference
so that means that he could evaluate
this counterfactual and so what we want
to do is to enable machines and
statisticians to do the same sort of
thing so that's pretty much the end of
my talk I just there's one more slide
here just for fun so after the book came
out I was like literally glued to
amazon.com because I wanted to see the
ranking how the book ranked and it
actually went into the top 100 which was
very exciting and so so I took a
screenshot to commemorate the occasion
and so there we are number 93 on the
Amazon top 100 and what I thought was
really funny was number 94 which
is called baby touch and feel animals so
this gives you an idea of the
competition if you want to write a
best-seller so so I thought we're doing
pretty well you know if you can write a
serious hard science book and have it
actually outsell a book with cute baby
bunnies on the cover then you must be
doing something right so I'll stop there
and if there any questions I'll be glad
to take them and also if anybody wants
to buy books I'll be glad to to sell
them to you or autograph them if you
already have one
so anyway questions so much
you know two or three one is when one
you know if one's falling aside the size
treatment that you know on the one hand
physical burden because you actually try
to what would we have it in some yes we
have yes
whereas when you are looking at diagrams
so for instance in the case of guitar
and and compounding in Banja essentially
you're trying to you know it's a much
simpler diagram you're trying to explain
it says that does not exist
anything pounding pattern which you know
which which directly on that affects the
time yeah on the one hand the much
simpler task on the other hand it's a
much bigger task and so you know just
just saying a little bit harder so you
know you talked about you know
publication
we need to say you know you know the
result of that study should be that that
either lung cancer causes yeah that's so
that's a very good way of putting it
yeah yeah that's that's great you make
so many good points there the one okay
one thing I do want to disagree with
which is these diagrams are a model okay
so you've been sort of contrasting these
two a model there a model there just a
simple qualitative model now you can
actually dress them up with all sorts of
detail and in fact you know completely
endorses that so
behind these arrows you can have
equations so if you have an arrow from a
and an arrow from B both leading to X
that could mean X is a function of a and
B and so you could get a model in the
classical physical sense of model where
X equals F of a be sure yeah
okay yeah yes right yeah okay
all right okay so then you you said
several things that were really great so
if I can remember them out so one thing
is yes so right the causal diagrams are
very qualitative model and certainly
more qualitative than people in the
physical sciences are used to working
with but the wonderful thing about them
the amazing thing about your day's work
is how much just this qualitative model
can tell you so for example if you have
a confounder it tells you that you need
to adjust for it and they're very simple
and actually fun rules for telling
exactly what variables you need to
control for and and which ones you don't
so that's one of the really cool things
and it is work and then you also
mentioned something that is not always
easy to realize when first blush which
is that the absence of an arrow is in
many cases more meaningful than the
presence of an arrow because the absence
of narrow actually means the
independence of the two variables given
the values of their parents so so
there's actually a statistical testable
assumption there so yeah so and in that
case of the front-door diagram certainly
the absence of an arrow from the smoking
gene tatar it's a big assumption and a
very powerful one which enables you to
to get your causal conclusion yeah how
do you select which nodes that you would
put on the front-door diagram for
example when I think about causation I
think back to the television commercials
of Margo role in the set so yeah so um
yeah and that's a good question so what
what things do we put in I don't know if
I should go back all the way what things
do we put into our diagram and what do
we not so ideally you'd put in
everything but that's a little bit
impractical and so there you have to use
your judgment as to what is really
having say a statistically significant
effect
and so if you think TV ads are you know
and if you think that that's somehow
different
you know the among the smoker is the
non-smokers something then then
absolutely you can put that in so the
diagram is only a way for conveying our
assumptions and as well as our existing
knowledge
else thank you very much thank you
[Applause]